[Musique]
je
bienvenue pierre bédier pour ce nouveau
numéro de vieilles pies au cours de
cette émission nous parlerons de vous de
votre parcours et puis de votre
actualité bien sûr puisque vous êtes en
pleine campagne pour l'élection à la
présidence des républicains dans le
département des yvelines
face à alexandra 10 blanche conseiller
régional qui allaient soutenu par
valérie pécresse s'est vite fait l'enjeu
c'est qu'on vous a posé plusieurs fois
la question mais pourquoi vous n'avez
pas réussi à vous mettre d'accord et
c'est ça mais si je le savais j'aurais
trouvé la solution bon bah écoutez on se
mettra d'accord après enfin je le
souhaite parce que nos militants ce qui
nous reste à mérite autre chose que des
petites bagarres subalterne
alexandra 10 blanche qui vous a appelé à
la rejoindre pour faire valoir votre
expérience à ses côtés j'avais même dit
mais viens moi j'avais commencé la
discussion avec elle il ya déjà
plusieurs mois
bon après je comme je ne veux pas de
polémique je ne dirais pas tous d'où ce
qu'ont été ces échanges
je pensais qu'on était plutôt bien parti
et puis non pour des raisons dont je
vais dire qu elle m'échappe même si elle
ne m'échappe pas les bouger la langue de
bois c'est terrible c'est comme ça
l'important encore une fois c'est
qu'après on redonne de l'espérance à nos
militants qui nous ont quittés en grand
nombre et si on continue nos bêtises à
nous diviser à nous lancer des boules
puantes bientôt n'aura plus de militants
et je suis de ceux qui pensent que les
militants sont le le sel sur le sel qui
nous permet de donner du goût à l'action
politique
donc vous n'êtes pas dans un climat de
tension de irréconciliables par la suite
de conflits de mon côté jamais moi je
veux rassembler ma famille politique je
voulais juste à l'admission sur
tellement je suis convaincu que c'est la
seule chemin verdict en tout cas lors du
vote des adhérents ce sera un 13 et 14
octobre pierre bédier donc président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
depuis le 11 avril 2014 vous l'avez
aussi été entre 2005 et 2009 vous avez
aussi été député de la 8e
circonscription ou encore maire de
mantes-la-jolie votre attachement au
département est plutôt fort et pourtant
n'être pas de la région vous venez de
mont-de-marsan
alors je suis né à mont de marsan parce
que maman est une femme de petit gabarit
et j'étais un gros bébé donc il valait
mieux que jeunesse à la clinique à
l'époque on essaie encore à la maison
donc en fait j'étais dans un petit
village du gers qui s'appelle castelnau
d'auzan maman était pharmacienne et je
suis allé mettre à mont de marsan dans
ces raisons techniques mais en fait je
suis gersois plus commandés alors
pourquoi cette arrivée dans le
département des yvelines
je suis ni migraine intérieur l'exode
rural les années 60 où un maman veut
passer d'une petite pharmacie de
campagne et une plus grande formation
ville donc j'arrive à poissy dans les
yvelines et j ai fait ma scolarité
je suis restée lorsque j'étais étudiant
je rentrai chez papa-maman le soir et
puis voilà et puis la vie politique m'a
amené à mantes la jolie dans les années
90 parce que le président chirac qui
n'était alors que président du rpr mais
merde pareille déjà était très colère de
l'alliance que la tête de liste udf
avait fait avec le front national et nos
amis du rpr donc j'ai été chargé de
mission pour à la fois mettre un terme à
cette alliance contre nature
déjà c'était déjà le débat et d'autre
part essayer de créer autour du rpr et
l'udf donc au tour des partis
traditionnels de droite une dynamique
pour relancer ce territoire et je suis
pas trop mal réussi cette mission
comment vous le justifier cet
attachement au territoire des désirs
line aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui vous a
plu dans ce territoire et qu'est ce qui
vous plaît aujourd'hui d'abord motion de
racines je crois que l'individu sans
racine est un individu perdu et donc des
racines de déraciner j'ai replanté dans
ce territoire et guy noah en profondeur
et à l'intérieur de ce territoire vis
moi j'aime toutes les yvelines mais
c'est vrai que j'ai une tendresse un peu
particulière pour la vallée de seine
pas simplement parce que elle a une
unique quand je fais mon footing du
dimanche matin c'est pour moi un immense
bonheur de le faire le long scène et je
comprends la passion qu'elle a suscitée
auprès des impressionnistes cette
lumière de la vallée de seine
mais c'est surtout que la vallée de
seine est aujourd'hui un résumé des
monts français et je trouve que c'est
c'est intéressant de s'attaquer à ces
mots certains c'est un territoire pas
d'expérimentations je déteste ce mot
c'est un territoire d'action et ça a
sans doute renforcé encore mon ancrage
c'est un territoire qui a de nombreux
visages aussi est ce que c'est possible
de gommer ou encore les inégalités qui
peuvent exister a justement cette c'est
un de mes grands combats et ce sont des
combats qui nous dépasse donc il faut
beaucoup de modestie quand on les aborde
parce qu on sait qu on les commence et
on sait qu'on ne l'ait finira pas je
crois pas l'éternité des hommes
politiques même si certains le croient
donc en tout cas bon moi c'est mon
combat et je le vis passionnément
voilà vous êtes attachés aux
départements des yvelines mais vous
aimeriez bien le voir fusionner avec les
hauts-de-seine aussi j'aurais tout parce
que moi je suis attaché pas une
institution
je crois qu'il faut surtout pas
croire que les institutions nous
appartiennent et qu'on peut les modeler
au gré de ses desiderata non sur quoi je
suis attaché son territoire en tant que
rassemblement de personnes est un
territoire sur lequel s'exercent des
politiques publiques
or je constate que les hauts-de-seine
c'est un petit territoire et par rapport
aux yvelines tout petit c'est un
douzième des yvelines s'est complètement
le prolongement quand vous le regardez
sur une carte qui est capable de me dire
où est la frontière entre le département
des yvelines et département des
hauts-de-seine personnes entre les les
le val d'oise pardon et les yvelines
vous avez la scène a tout à fait la
scène mais vous avez la scène avec les
hauts-de-seine
quand vous êtes au haras de jardy bien
malin celui qui ce qu'il est dans les
hauts de seine dans les yvelines et nous
avons les mêmes politiques publiques
donc je crois que la fusion de ces deux
départements pour faire un département
qui est une institution de proximité
donc une institution utile à l'exercice
de la démocratie et des solidarités qui
font de cette démocratie
oui ça je crois que cette fusion là a du
sens après des fusions beaucoup plus
grande
on m'avait dit mais pourquoi vous voulez
pas recréer la scène c'est à dire
fusionné avec le val d'oise et l'essonne
mais parce que tout simplement ce serait
un territoire bien tropisme ans pour le
coup c'est à dire que pour aller à evry
pour aller à nanterre une fois une
demi-heure de versailles pour aller
livrer une fois une heure et demie donc
c'est pas tout à fait la même histoire
et pour aller à cergy pontoise une fois
une heure parce que ce qui est aussi
cessé la logique française et
francilienne ce qui est aussi terrible
c'est que nous n'avons pas développer
les structures les infrastructures
pardon de transport qui permettent de
passer en grande couronne
nous sommes toujours dans ce système
d'aller vers le centre où d'en partir
qui fait qu'en réalité avec les
hauts-de-seine nous partageons les
autoroutes
nous partageons les voies ferrées nous
partageons les routes donc la fluidité
ce fait tout à fait naturellement c'est
une preuve que la décentralisation
encore dû encore du travail à faire pour
un moule que puisse arriver sur la
décentralisation je parlais de 4 celle
de paris c'est aussi votre combat aussi
de décentraliser
aujourd'hui on attendait bien sûr dans
le monde entier que ce soient les états
où que ce soit les entreprises
l'idée c'est comment on donne plus de
proximité il ya encore qu'en france où
donner de la proximité fait peur l'état
nous explique que nous on est de mauvais
gestionnaires
quand on voit dans quel état et l'état
dont le déficit n'est pas de 3% vrai
quand on vous parle de 3% le déficit
quoi en l'état il est de 30 %
c'est-à-dire que vous avez un état qui
depuis 40 ans dépensent un tiers de plus
que ce qu'il encaisse et ces gens là
viennent nous expliquer que transférer
aux élus locaux des responsabilités
c'est prendre le risque de la mauvaise
gestion
c'est grotesque on parle de votre
attachement département des yvelines
on pourrait aussi parler de votre
attachement à votre famille politique
vous avez rejoint le rpr en 1976 à
l'issue d'une réunion à sa création à
l'issue d'une réunion de jacques chirac
justement et vous aviez 19 ans vous nous
raconter un petit peu ce moment oui
parce que en fait bois j'étais étudiant
à sciences po à paris les sciences po
paris tout le monde était rocardienne
mois à 18 ans on n'a pas une
personnalité je n'avais pas une
personnalité très affirmée
donc je me voyais bien parti pour pour
devenir un gentil un gentil rocardien et
puis cette année qui m'a amené qui était
gaulliste qui m'a amené au meeting de
fondation du rpr
cette ambiance une ambiance extrêmement
chaleureuse extrêmement populaire
c'était la formule d'andré malraux 1
le rpr du rpf à l'époque mais dans leur
père est le descendant c'est le métro à
cinq heures du soir
tu vois j'ai aimé j'ai rencontré des
gens que je connaissais donc voilà c'est
parti comme ça c'est d'abord pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord une histoire
humaine
une histoire de rencontre une histoire
de partage une histoire d' équipe
mais comment ça se traduit ensuite sur
le terrain vous allez militez vous
faites des campagnes vous organisez des
ingénieurs fournissions j'avais la
solution puisque j'étais petit
technocrates potentiel puisque je
faisais des études de sciences
politiques à paris
donc bon c'était là la légine à fournir
les candidats à l'ena ça veut pas dire
naturellement que j'aurais fait un
énarque j'aurais sans doute pas eu de
concours et si je l'avais huchon a été
sans doute très indocile et assez peu
favorable à un état centralisé mais
toujours est il que j'ai préféré la voie
militante
donc je me suis retrouvé délai les
jeunes de ma circonscription et puis
adjoint au département donc on
organisait des distributions décollage
on allait à l'époque on faisait des
sorties d'usiné j'étais aussi étudiant
un an père j'étais en licence pour qu'on
se chauffer un peu les oreilles avec les
trotskistes connu les assemblées
générales où les trotskistes faisait
voter la grève par cinq types au milieu
de cinq cents bon c'était c'était des
moments dans le folklore politique et
étudiants de l'époque qui a bien changé
maintenant on est plus sur les réseaux
sociaux et voilà et moi j'ai toujours
été habité par cette idée que l'on la
politique c'est d'abord une aventure
collective ça doit être vécue
collectivement vous êtes nostalgique de
cette époque nous écoute parler les
joueurs on est hors de nostalgique de sa
jeunesse donc
oui bien sûr mais je crois que on a tout
pour recréer les mêmes conditions dans
cette époque
après moi je ne pense pas qu'il faille
il faut moins de charges et j'ai envie
de dire les hommes politiques quand je
vais vous dire une bêtise mais c'est
pour essayer de justifier mon
raisonnement plutôt que de changer les
responsables politiques il faut changer
les pratiques polydor bien souvent c'est
vrai que ces pratiques politiques sont
liées aux hommes politiques mais lorsque
si je pouvais arriver à faire revivre
cette idée que mes maîtres m'ont
enseigné l'échelle péricard les franck
borotra les henri cuq cette idée que la
politique c'est un collectif c'est un
travail d'équipé sion peut remettre ça
au goût du jour dans les yvelines
je serai le plus heureux des hommes mais
il ya une déception peut être
aujourd'hui de la part des électeurs
aussi bien sur les électeurs ils ont le
sentiment à torre raison parce que il ya
aussi un jeu médiatique ne fait pas
grief aux médias mais je dis que
certains savent mieux se servir des
médias que notre linge médiatique qui
fait croire que quand la droite arrive
au pouvoir et fait la politique de la
gauche
et d'ailleurs les mêmes après explique
que quand la gauche arriver au pouvoir
et fait la politique de la voix tout ce
qui est en train d'arriver à monsieur
maquereau en réalité non mais sans doute
avons-nous été insuffisamment pédagogue
sans doute n'avons nous pas de chance
moi j'ai le souvenir
jacques chirac devenant premier ministre
de cohabitation
c'est le grand krach financier wall
street 1986 où cette enchère a bien
arrivé nicolas sarkozy élu en 2007 c'est
quand même le grand krach de 2008 qui
avait submergé la planète d'un désastre
économique donc c'est vrai que on arrive
au pouvoir avec une volonté
et puis cette volonté elle est un peu
tendue par les fêtes et on s'est sans
doute pas en faire suffisamment la
pédagogie nous a peut être manqué à
droite ce qu'ont eue les états unis à
une époque de leur existence qui était
le grand communicant qui a été ronald
reagan
ronald reagan il a fait changer la
politique américaine
c'était pas un génie de la politique
incontestablement mais il avait cette
capacité à expliquer votre première
élection un poste important députation
avril 93 puis juin 95 maire de
mantes-la-jolie à ce moment là vous vous
dites que ce sont des étapes dans une
carrière politique ou c'est un premier
accomplissement pour mettre en pratique
aussi vos idées je m'ai fait carrière
pour moi la politique c'est pas une
carrière c'est une passion et c'est pas
des mots comme ça pas de l'acquis
potager je suis comme ça voilà moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de faire avant
j'avais créé mon entreprise parce que
j'aimais faire plutôt qu obéir en
politique ça a été un peu pareil j'étais
plus disciplinés sans doute en politique
et donc quand je suis élu en 93 je suis
stupéfait parce que je m'y attendais
vraiment pas je suis candidat je suis un
candidat de témoignage d'une
circonscription très à gauche
qui avait été redécoupée et les parties
les plus à droite avaient été enlevées
pour être mise justement dans la
circonscription d'henri cuq au kop
j'étais pas bien parti et puis je me
suis retrouvé face à l'effondrement de
la gauche avec une poussée fn donc un
deuxième tour rpa fn que j'ai remporté
60 40 quand même donc c'était déjà dire
que ce territoire était en grande
souffrance
et puis alors l'amérique manteau ça
c'est autre chose
de toutes les élections que j'ai eu à
connaître c'est sans doute celle qui m'a
le plus ému pas et mention de la
victoire on est contents non sur les
tables quand on gagne mais une
responsabilité quand vous devenez maire
vous sentais confusément que vous êtes
en responsabilité d'une collectivité
mais d'une collectivité c'est à dire de
famille dans l'île c'est vrai que dans
la fonction mer les choses quand vous
allez voir une dame dont le mari est
porté disparu en mer quand vous allez
voir des parents dont l'enfant a été tué
par un chauffard dans la ville en
brûlant un feu
c'est ce sont des après ça vous donne un
lien singulier avec les habitants et
avec avid c'est le poste le plus
important pour vous celui de mère
justement
jeanne est toujours un peu la nostalgie
je m'éclate comme président du conseil
départemental on a des projets
formidables des élus kurdes du gaz une
administration qui bosse donc je suis
plutôt un homme heureux
mais on voit pas autant les résultats de
ces actions
quand vous êtes mère ma plus grande
fierté quand j'ai été élu maire sait
qu'en trois mois la ville et des propres
parce que j'ai dit la priorité
je veux plus un papier grave non plus de
crottes de chiens je veux que les gens
quand ils invitent leurs familles et qui
sortent se promener dans la ville ils
soient fiers de leur ville ça commence
par la propreté
donc on a mis des moyens supplémentaires
et je les ai vus tout de suite quand je
décide quelque chose dans mon bureau
versaillais je suis pas toujours sûr que
à rambouillet ou à bonnières ça soit
bien suivies d'effet on parle un petit
peu encore de votre carrière politique
vous mais aussi secrétaire d'état
pendant un temps mais vous êtes frappé
d'inégibilité
sans revenir sur ce moment là cette
affaire là ce que je voudrais savoir
c'est ce que vous vous êtes dit à ce
moment là
votre carrière même si vous n'aimez pas
le mode carrière vous venez de le dire
politique c'était terminé pour vous
qu'il fallait passer à autre chose
est-ce que vous avez été soutenue est ce
que vous vous êtes senti seul
humainement comment vous avez vécu ce
moment là un an je me suis jamais senti
seul parce que j'ai des gens absolument
extraordinaire formidable auprès de
moins bons qui ont assisté à ce truc un
peu curieux la justice a toujours raison
je suis républicain donc la justice a
toujours raison même quand elle a tort
non et en l'espèce je reviendrai pas là
dessus alors après la question que je me
suis posée c'est est ce que ça vaut le
coup d'imposer aux siens parce que
surtout pas la famille que c'est dur
tous les années du combat politique dont
je parlais bon ça fait partie du combat
politique
la famille c'est un peu plus compliqué
donc me su poser des questions est ce
que j'arrête est-ce que je continue je
me suis tranquillement donné deux ans
deux ans à faire autre chose d'abord il
a fallu que je travaille et parce que là
du jour au lendemain
et comme j'étais devenu entend animer un
professionnel de la politique que je
n'avais pas d'autre activité moi je
pense aux actionnaires jetons
fonctionnaires pas rejoint mon corps
d'origine avec le salaire qu'il tombe en
fin de mois donc bon il a fallu se
bagarrer recréer une entreprise j'ai
retrouvé d'ailleurs un certain plaisir
ça a été un peu dur j'avais perdu les
réflexes au début
c'est un truc tout bête à un des rares
avant d'acheter politique dans les
missions qui étaient les miennes c'était
la voiture avec chauffeur tout d'un coup
faire monter dans leur voiture
elle a pris quelques coups au démarrage
parce que j'ai reperdu ils vont faire
avec pendant les vacances
bon donc vous retrouvez la vraie vie ça
ça fait au début si rude mais après ça
fait un bien fou dit à tenter si même
d'ailleurs que maintenant je prends ma
voiture quelquefois tout seul parce que
voilà obligé quand même ne pas devenir
veut pas reconnaître ce que j'ai connu
mais au delà de cette anecdote je
m'étais donné deux ans pour savoir est
ce que tu veux revenir on pas et je suis
revenu parce que j'ai la passion la
passion de l'action publique
je crois qu'il ya rien de plus
satisfaisant pour moi je dis pas que
c'est vrai pour tout le monde
après chacun fait ce qu'il veut que de
servir l'intérêt général c'est voilà ça
cette créativité au service de l'intérêt
général ça c'est je trouve que c'est
mieux je me sens mieux que dans
l'entreprise et d'ailleurs je me définis
comme un entrepreneur public
je trouve ça mieux que d'être
entreprenants privée et quand vous voyez
l'évolution de la politique aujourd'hui
vous ne vous dites pas que finalement
c'était mieux avant est ce que vous vous
retrouverez sa foi ça fait un peu vieux
c'est au n comme ça lorsque je vois les
partis traditionnels qui ont du mal on
voit les lignes politiques qui vole en
éclat un peu partout quelle que soit la
formation gauche droite
ouais surtout de pas plus mal parce
qu'on évite comme ça les a priori
idéologiques et donc sonné on est sans
doute plus concret est-ce que c'était
mieux avant honnêtement je suis pas sur
moi ce qui me manque je l'avouer mais m
ceux qui m'ont précédé qui m'ont tout
appris
parce que quelquefois j'aurais envie de
je prétends pas tous avoir un jour à
l'envi leur poser la question qu'est ce
qu'on fait bon mais alors du coup
maintenant je me sens certaines
responsabilités
le panneau rentrer c'est celui de la
transmission si je suis candidat à la
présidence de la fédération
je suis bien conscient que ce n'est pas
un poulet de l'année
mais pourquoi je fais ça pour ajouter à
ma gloire c'est que je pense que si on
ne sait pas d'où on vient et comment on
fait c'est très difficile d'aller de
l'avant
donc mon rôle c'est d'être un rôle de
transmetteur voilà je suis à un âge où
il faut que je sois conscient que la
transmission s'impose à moi et je pense
que c'est vraiment l'intérêt de notre
fédération des de notre mouvement règle
générale que d'avoir cessé passeur
d'expérience en étant sur la ligne
politique de laurent wauquiez
est ce que vous vous y retrouvez sur
cette ligne politique moi je sais pas ce
qu'est la ligne politique de laurent
wauquiez moi j'ai rencontré laurent
wauquiez à l'occasion je ne connaissais
pas jamais vu et comme je me méfie
beaucoup de ce qu'on raconte sur les uns
ou sur les autres dans les médias
j'ai trouvé plus simple d'aller lui
parler directement chalet lui parler
dans sa ville qui était ville étape du
tour de france je ne profitais comme ça
pour suivre le tour que je n'avais
jamais fait est formidable je ne lui ai
posé qu'une question jeudi laurent
alliance balian savait que feront date
il m'a dit jamais bon ben voilà c'est
tout après bien sûr que j'ai des
divergences avec laurent wauquiez comme
jamais avec valérie pécresse comme
jamais avec moins souvent avec les rares
marchés
voilà xavier bertrand qui est qui et
plus chez nous
bien entendu on n'est pas tous pareils
on ne pense pas tous la même chose mais
sur l'essentiel
nous sommes d'accord ce que je regrette
un peu aujourd'hui c'est que à des fins
je comprends l'ambition personnelle mais
parfois elle est quand même un peu
usante pour les autres cette ambition
personnelle
on cherche toujours à mettre l'accent
sur ce qui nous divise plutôt que ce qui
nous rassemble a donc comme je ne suis
candidat à rien d'autre qu'à la
présidence de la fédé moi je souhaite
mettre l'accent sur tout ce qui vous
rassemble plutôt que ce qui nous divise
la version pour le front national vous
l'avez toujours eu oui parce que je
pense que il nous faut faire totalement
fausse route
or après je dialogue avec les électeurs
du front national parce qu'il faut les
ramener chez nous bien entendu ils font
fausse route quand vous avez quelqu'un
qui va dans une impasse et à toute
vitesse vous le laissez pas aller se
fracasser contre le mur vous essayé de
lui expliquer que au bout de la rue ya
le mur donc
cette aversion elle est plus à l'égard
des dirigeants du front national qui
racontent n'importe quoi qui vivent
d'ailleurs à linverse des principes
qu'ils affichent mais sans un grand
classique donc on ne dira rien mais bien
entendu j'ai une aversion du front
national parce que ils font pas du bien
la france mais le front national qui
pourrait éventuellement disparaître en
tout cas c'est ce que dit marine le pen
vous y croyez pas ce que c'est de la
communication aussi est ce que le front
national ne vit que nos propres
insuffisances
moi j'ai été élu contre le front
national en 1993 compte en triangulaire
avec un front national qui était à plus
de 30% à des cantonales en 94 m et
municipales de 95 en 1995 premier tour
43% pour moi 30 % le front national 2e
tour 47% pour moi et 26% pour front
national donc il ya 4 900 d'électeurs fn
qui se disent plutôt que d'avoir la
gauche on va quand même allés voter pour
la droite mais je fais pas la majorité
absolue et six ans plus tard je fais 59%
des voix et le front national disparaît
quasiment la monte et depuis a plus de
front national donc qu'est ce qu'il
s'est passé j'ai dialogué avec les
acteurs français quand ils demandent de
la sécurité je vais pas leur dire c'est
un sentiment d'insécurité qui vous
habite charme monsieur tout va bien si
la silla un coquard parce que il s'est
fait voler sa voiture dans la rue donc
bien entendu qu'il faut apporter des
réponses
les questions qui sont posées c'était
fabuleux ce qu'ils disaient ça il pose
les bonnes questions il apporte les
mauvaises réponses
j'adhère à cette définition est donc si
nous ne savons pas apporté les réponses
et c'est manifestement le cas
aujourd'hui ça continuera à la dérive
et c'est sur tous les sujets on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler mais par
exemple parce que ça sera d'actualité
l'année prochaine sur le sujet européen
avec cette élection européenne en 2019
revenu un petit peu sur ce terrain sur
ce département des yvelines puisqu'on
arrive bientôt à la fin de cette
émission est ce que vous avez des des
regrets des projets que vous n'avez pas
pu mener
je pense par exemple à ce projet de
circuit de formule 1 au caj côté de fuir
et bien voilà c'est à votre regret on se
plaint des regrets je peux pas trop le
dire parce que ça
gray man bonne opposition qui dit ren ce
type d'accueil des échecs et oui il y en
a eu pas mal d échec mais je crois que
quand on essaye de faire il faut
accepter qui est qui et du déchet sur le
circuit de formule 1 je regrette
vraiment pas ce que l'espèce de
fanatisme écologique que de certains est
à l'opposé de la réalité et je
n'oublierai jamais cette image parce
qu'on avait réalisé un petit film où on
voyait ce manifestants arrivés en
voiture pour protester contre le circuit
automobile descendre de sa voiture vers
le coffre de sa voiture s'en tire avec
au pliage et se rendre à la
manifestation en vélo quelle hypocrisie
bien entendu que notre planète est
menacée bien entendu qu'il faut de
l'écologie mais le grand prix de formule
1 électrique qui se passe actuellement
appareil qui lui ne pollue pas vous
croyez pas que ça serait mieux le voir
dans les yvelines sur un territoire un
peu abîmée comme l'est la vallée de
seine et puis sur un territoire où
l'automobile est primordiale une journée
premier département automobile de france
c'est elle qui nous lient au liban bref
c'est comme ça la vie politique
ça n'est pas comme je voulais dit que
des succès ou des satisfactions et le
projet le plus important qu'il vous
reste à accomplir
j'en ai plusieurs d'abord je pense que
on aura vraiment remis decker les
finances du département ce qui n'était
pas évident vu les attaques que l'état
nous avait fait subir
j'ai demandé aux yvelinois d'y
participer mais on leur rend termes
d'investissements bien au delà de ce
qu'ils ont pu investir donc c'est une
opération rentable pour eux donc ça
c'est à misano mal est fait ensuite le
sujet peut-être le petit effet papillon
de mon passage à la présence du conseil
départemental ça va être le nouveau
collège qu'on va construire un qui est
un collège totalement révolutionnaire
dans la pédagogie avec l'éducation
nationale
je crois que l'éducation c'est le plus
important de toutes les responsabilités
qui sont les nôtres et je pense que
c'est au collège que les choses
commencent à déraper donc agir là dessus
si ça marche je ne le saurai que dans
quelques années je serais heureux parce
que je pense que j'aurais apporté une
contribution essentielle
et si tout le monde l'a oublié mais que
ça a marché j'en serai ravi
merci beaucoup pierre vous pouvoir
participer à ce vieil pays président du
conseil départemental est donc candidat
à la présidence des républicains dans
les yvelines
[Musique]